[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's more to sight than just being
able to see the crowd
you can definitely feel
the atmosphere
there's a vibe in the air there's the
energy in the air there's the sound
it's amazing to hear the fans
especially when we run out of tunnel
i'm jake wilson i'm the long snapper of
the university of southern california
trojans i'm completely blind i have no
eyes
i went into playing football with the
mentality that i had nothing to lose
long stopping is an art
you definitely have the mechanics but a
lot of us just feel feeling that ball
coming off your fingertips in a spiral
how hard you're throwing it you know
where you're releasing it just kind of
getting that velocity and that and the
accuracy
life's unfair football is unfair but at
the same time
it's up to you of how far
you want to take yourself
when i was eight months old i was
diagnosed with a rare form of eye cancer
called retinoblastoma
when the doctors found my cancer
it was completely taken over my left eye
so they almost immediately removed my
left eye
from there on you know just a cycle of
you know the cancer coming back then we
fight it with treatments
doctors finally said listen we pretty
much exhausted all all treatment options
the safer option is just you know the
removal of the eye
growing up in the 2000s where coach
carroll was
so dominant with usc it was hard not to
be a usc
fan i always loved football i continued
to play flag football my eighth grade
year after losing my sight it was not
anything close to tackle football
as i entered high school i decided not
to play football for my freshman and
sophomore year it really was something i
didn't think i could do but eventually
my love for the game really overcame any
doubts and i learned how to be an asset
money
i just love the camaraderie of football
i love being part of the team love
putting on you know just the pads and
the jersey and stuff and
being part of the team was enough just
to get me to try
[Music]
[Music]
girls are just as good as boys in
anything
we know how to hit
[Music]
we know how to run
and we can definitely play football
go go go so when i heard boys chanting
beat that girl beat that girl
all it made me want to do was beat them
even better
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sam gordon i'm 14 years old and i
started the first female tackle football
league
i've been playing with the boys since i
was 9 years old
in my very first season i scored 35
touchdowns got like 1900 yards
sometimes after i'd beat them the
parents would come out onto the field
and grab their son's face masks and be
like don't let a girl beat you
i wanted to start the girls tackle
football league after talking at a
school assembly and asking the question
how many girls here would want to play
tackle football
almost every hand in the room went up so
i got the idea like okay if there's this
many at this one school imagine how many
there are in utah or just in the nation
so i talked to my dad and he talked with
some other people after a while we had
the first season of the utah girls taco
football league up and running
hey let's go
football is the last frontier in girls
sports and if you think about it girls
can play on girls teams in every sport
that you can think of except for the
country's most popular sport
[Music]
limited participation to 50 girls those
spots filled up in less than a week the
following year we had 100 girls and then
this season we've had over 200 girls who
are playing
every year we keep getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
it would be amazing for it to go into
high schools colleges and even its own
professional league
and that's going to be a tough goal to
reach but i am really ambitious and i
feel like we can do it with the girls
you can tell that everybody really wants
to be there and so everybody's just
super into it and always willing to
learn
with the girls every practice is just an
awesome time
[Music]
okay squad listen up
there's more than one way to end a game
with sports ball
there's the walk-off home run
the sudden death gold
the buzzer beater
but within the adrenaline adult psyche
of the american sports fan can any of
them produce a heart attack like a
successful hail mary pass don't answer
that it's rhetorical
why are hail marys special because
they're unicorns since 1975 there's only
been 28 of them in professional football
why because they're almost impossible to
get right to complete a hail mary the
past needs to be long like thrown from
midfield long with little or no time
remaining on the clock and you need to
be losing and the pass must lead to a
touchdown that results in at least a tie
but preferably a win that is a hail mary
most quarterbacks are likelier to marry
a supermodel than to throw a successful
hail mary in their career exhibit a tom
brady
so how did this play which practically
requires an act of god to come to pass
see what i did there easy with a prayer
[Music]
hail mary full of grace the lord is with
thee
so it's december 28 1975
50 yards from the end zone but needing a
touchdown to win
cowboys quarterback and devout catholic
roger staubach whispers a hail mary to
himself hell mary full of grace the lord
is with thee and launches a desperation
pass to receiver drew pearson the
cowboys win and the hail mary is
christened forevermore
any questions good now go win me some
ball games
[Music]
it's a 360 degree game there's no
padding there is a high risk involved in
it because it is a full contact sport
and yeah you really can cop it from any
angle but we're pretty tough and we get
straight back up from tuffy's first goal
i'm chloe malloy and i'm a women's
footballer
let's go girls
[Music]
afl or the australian football league is
best described as a combination of rugby
football and soccer i think if you ask
any australian it's a really big deal it
defines us it's a part of our culture i
think everyone has an afl team that they
support
my uncle played football for collingwood
so i grew up watching him and i
immediately wanted to do it
back when i was a little girl i actually
played football for three to four years
but then there's that drop-off that a
lot of girls have
because there is no pathway into a
women's sporting career
in 2017 a women's league was officially
introduced
good stretch from the all australian
the afl women's changed the path of life
for me that i never thought i'd have
great work in the contest from chloe
malloy it's brought out the little
girl's dream that i had back when i did
play football
i think the afl women's is breaking down
a lot of barriers that once existed
amongst women in sport no matter what
race what sexual identity you are it
really doesn't matter and anyone can
play
some people just don't agree that women
should be playing football so that's
probably a challenge that i face and
that the whole league face as well
the best way to react to all the
criticism is just not to react at all
and keep doing what we enjoy
one hope that i have is that if any
little girl or boy clicks on the tv they
know full well that that's a sport that
they can go into no matter if it's being
played by men or women
[Music]
[Music]
how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything
we have the opportunity to do something
that no one else does this isn't played
anywhere else in the world so yeah like
it's serious like we want to win
[Music]
we're here to watch unicycle football
it's football on unicycles
[Music]
we stick the nfl rules as closely as
possible
so there are a few exceptions because
we're riding a unicycle
we play five on five two receivers a
blocker a center and a quarterback
everything has to be done on a wheel
the second your foot touches the ground
you're done
each team plays 14 games there's 56
regular season games total then wild
card playoffs then playoffs and then the
super bowl every sunday some people have
been doing this for 10 years now
my team the black house we're undefeated
and we're gonna be playing the reigning
champs the herons
bulldoze them over bulldozer this game
is very important because we want to
maintain our undefeated status leading
up to the super bowl they're definitely
gunning for us they're practicing just
for us
i think that a lot of times people come
to this game what shocks them
is the level of play
we're crashing at 15 miles an hour it's
not a joke
some people get seriously injured
most people learn to ride unicycle
because they came and witnessed this
event and i'm like i've got to do this
once you catch that first ball
once you get that first rush once you
hear the crowd scream your name once
that's a feeling you can't get anywhere
else that's almost like a religion
church to us here
there's passion you know it's a show
it's a spectacle
it's also a sport
i've cherished every minute of it it's
you can't replace it with anything
there's nothing else like it
at all
[Music]
you